[Music]
the long-term plan or ltp
may sound a tad boring but it's so
important
for waimakariri because it helps define
how we're going to grow
and the rates we're going to pay dan i
can't believe you're in the same park at
the same time
john i can't believe i've seen you here
in fact i've never seen you before it's
lovely to meet you
well listen as a stranger ltp yeah so
we're coming into council's long-term
plan so basically it's our budget
and so this is the things that we're
looking at is the sort of growth that
we've got in our district
the sort of needs that we have and how
we're going to pay for them
the ltp budgets for the council's
critical work
roads pipes and rubbish collections but
also
places that provide a sense of community
such as
libraries pools parks and of course
sports facilities so
each ltp is a balancing act between what
the district needs
what the residents want and what the
council can afford
so if there's something the public want
the council to do or indeed
don't want the council to do now's the
time to tell us
to find out more visit waimakarari.gov
dot nz forward slash let's talk